[Music]
in 2077 they voted my city the worst
place to live in America main issues sky
high rate of violence and more people
living below the poverty line that
anywhere else
can't deny it it's all true everybody
still wants to live here
the city's always got a promise for you
might be a lie an illusion
it's there just around the corner
thank you going
the universe of sub punk was based on
our timeline except with an alternative
history and a dystopian future that is
heavily focused on tech and cybernetics
dating back to the 80s a number of
significant events have occurred in
history that have lead to a collection
of altered outcomes and as a result the
globe has been plagued by famine trade
wars biological warfare societal
collapse and eventually the breakdown of
governments in the chaos a number of
major corporations stepped in to fill
the positions of power around the world
technological advances radically
multiplied as they were no longer
restricted by governments which in turn
led to hundreds of new highly
questionable conventions some of the
bigger corporations grew to be larger
and more powerful than the countries
they call home and coincidentally with
power comes domination so over time what
has left of the world's governments are
so heavily influenced by the
corporation's they work with that they
may as well not even exist because of
this it's led to a number of corporate
Wars each one more deadly than the last
the story behind cyberpunk actually
originates from a tabletop game that was
created in the 80s and has been
developing and growing ever since so
there is almost 40 years of law backing
cyberpunk 2077 seriously I've been
reading up on it over the last few days
and I've barely scratched the surface
the story behind it is huge this video
is just a quick run-through of what we
know so far to get a bit of a feel for
the sitting and preparation for the game
release later this year if there is
interest I'm pretty keen to go through
some of the major events in history that
have led us to the present time end game
2077 so let me know in the comments
otherwise let's crack into it
the survey fact universe is an
alternative reality to earth sit in the
near future where crime is at an
all-time high and death is a common
occurrence on the streets wealthy
corporations are rampant and have become
more powerful than the world's
governments and just like a number of
countries the United States too is
forced to rely on these large
corporations in order to survive these
companies deal in a wide range of
sectors including weapons robotics
cybernetics pharmaceuticals
biotechnology and communications and
many of these companies operate well
above the law the series is set in night
city a fictional West Coast metropolis
situated between Los Angeles and San
Francisco said to have a population of
around 5 million although this is much
likely higher in 2077 global superpowers
have collapsed leaving Earth's fate at
the hands of large corporations that
frequently bicker amongst themselves for
world dominance drought and disease run
rampant and as a result massive famines
have occurred in the Middle East has
become a radioactive desert techno shock
is a widespread mental disorder as many
people are unable to cope with the
synthetic muscle tissue organic circuits
and designer drugs with the absence of
the government and its military forces
casual violence is becoming a growing
epidemic the world and its people are
subjected to ongoing conflicts between
rival gangs and its ruling entities
fighting for territories and ultimately
control the internet is regulated
continually by these corporations and
the army personnel homelessness is
exceedingly high but this doesn't mean
that the poor are excluded from
cybernetic modification it's just not as
safe effective and aesthetically
pleasing as the more expensive
alternatives
as a result of the never-ending threat
to life all citizens are allowed to own
and openly carry firearms in public
the cyberpunk game takes place in night
city which is located on the west coast
of the United States in the free state
of Northern California free states are
still part of the Union of the USA but
are now independent they can declare
federal laws as invalid and create their
own the first state to declare itself a
free state was Texas in 1999 which was
then renamed to the Republic of Texas
after the government tried to regulate
its weapons subsequently Texas was then
followed by Alaska in 2000 California in
2002 Nevada and 2003 and Utah in 2014
eventually in 2012 Northern California
then broke away from the rest of
California becoming the Free State of
Northern California with the remainder
tuning into the Free State of Southern
California night City is located just
north of the Free State of Southern
California and in real life is the Morro
Bay Area night city's original name is
going to be coronado city and was the
brainchild of businessman Richard Knight
who'd become displeased with his
encounters with in corporate
construction projects as part of his
company
Paisley ferris and night this eventually
led him to breaking away and forming his
own company Knight international with
the ultimate goal of creating the
perfect city he envisioned an idyllic
utopia in which other cities across the
country look to them as the future gold
standard shortly after the breakdown
many of the mecca Corpse also looked at
creating such a space where crime and
poverty were non-existent and the
freedom to choose their own laws was
granted so as not to impede this
sometimes and if it will work by 1992
corporations like arasaka EBM and petra
kim had all invested heavily in coronado
city night purchased many of the rights
as well as the subsequent land
surrounding del Coronado Bay from Petra
Kim in order to secure a site for the
new city by 1993 construction of the
city was well underway the bay had been
drenched and the upper peninsula had
been extended
in existing residents of del Coronado
were relocated to new districts known as
old downtown and the central hub of the
city where the corporations were based
would be the new downtown area in 1998
Knight was killed by an organized crime
syndicate in retaliation for being
kicked out of Coronado city's
construction from there onwards the
city's name was changed to Knight city
and his honor following on from his
death several factions fought for
control local mobsters battled against
big corporations which resulted in
anarchy in several sectors and the
police force quickly became ineffective
against such groups by 2005 the mob had
total control of the city's
infrastructure and the corporation's who
had no desire to govern retreat back to
the corporate strongholds and the
suburbs the period between 2009 and 2011
was known as the mob walls and night
city had grown to be an incredibly
violent murderous and highly active gang
metropolis it's unclear whether the mega
cops attempted to deal with the mob
during this time but it is well known
that the mob was bad business for the
mega force eventually the conflict was
resolved with heavily armed arasaka
paramilitaries boredom by the MiG Pope's
trip to the streets and force in
overwhelmed the monsters in turn living
them effectively defeated there
afterwards the corporation's installed
puppets into local government and
positions of influence and began the
process of cleaning up the war-torn city
the city's homelessness had by now grown
out of control and new laws had come
into effect stating that anyone without
finances to renovate their home would be
removed by now almost all of the city's
affordable housing was occupied by
corpse troops resulting in the
displacement of hundreds of residents
by the year 2020 the mop wars were a
distant memory and night city had become
a relatively peaceful place with the
downtown district being continually
policed at all times however many
dangers still remained and the scars of
previous conflicts have not yet healed
weapons are prevalent in everyone's
day-to-day lives and it's not uncommon
to see a gun as often as you'd see a
cellphone the cyberpunk 2077 story goes
on to follow a mercenary outlaw who goes
by the name like feet he is a hired gun
on the rise in night City the most
violent and dangerous metropolis of the
corporate world future going after one
of a kind implant that is the key to
immortality I'll be the first to admit I
wasn't particularly excited for this
game it seemed a little overhyped
and I've been burned enough times from
clever marketing to fall for another one
but after really digging in to see what
I could find I must say I'm very
interested to see what comes from this
the depth of the lower lung has will be
right in as I said earlier this was
really just meant as a summary of what
we currently know about the city of the
game there are so many things I could
talk about regarding mega-corporations
and the events in the past has led to
the sudden funk world to the state it's
currently aired
anyway thank you very much for watching
don't forget to add me on all the social
links in the description Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]